[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Приазов'я
Заповідник Асканія-Нова]
Звірята, привіт!
Звірята, йдіть сюди!
Тут, бачите, такий сурогат
із бурчеллових зебр,
коней Прживальського,
аж там антилопи гну,
[Віктор Гавриленко
Директор Асканії-Нової]
антилопи нільгау,
і... хто там у нас ще мешкає?
Йди сюди, Лапульчику.
Привіт, Лапочко.
Молодець, смакоту приніс.
А ти хочеш спробувати? На!
На, спробуй хліб.
Ах, ти мій козлюньчик.
Двотижневий.
Зверніть увагу: це природний степ Асканії.
Він простягається на 18 км.
Дійсно, це найбільший заповідний степ Європи.
Ось він перед нами.
Більшого клаптика землі не можна
знайти в межах України.
І далі чорна смуга йде по степу, ви бачите?
Оце як раз та фальцфейнівська борозна,
яка була закладена у 1898 році.
Фальц-Фейн побачив, що його вівці
знищують степову рослинність,
і поставив собі на мету зберегти
в природному стані такий шмат степу.
Він наказав обкопати 510 десятин.
І заповідав на вічні часи.
Оце в Україні залишалось 32 пари.
Минулого року до нас прилетіло на зимівлю 8 500.
Однозначно, це результат роботи наших асканійських вчених.
Ми дійсно відновили популяцію огарів в Україні.
Коли ми бачимо нові сафарі-парки,
вони створюються за образом Асканії-Нової.
Величезні загони, в яких
напіввільно живуть тварини.
Кажу чесно, про Асканію-Нову я безумовно знав,
як і всі діти колишнього Радянського Союзу,
вивчав у книжці, тобто підручнику.
Тоді я хотів взагалі працювати в лісі.
Я працював у державному
лісовому заповіднику Кодри.
12 років прожив серед лісу
за 5 км від населеного пункту.
Тому я кажу своїм колегам,
що я серед них найдикіший.
[сміється]
Ніхто стільки років не прожив за межами населеного пункту, у дикій природі.
І, власне, тоді ще був такий момент:
мій батько був при смерті,
перед цим я прилетів,
я родом з Бердянського району Запорізької області,
я прилетів до батька, і батько каже:
«Синку, от було б добре,
якби тебе перекинули в Асканію.
Там теж заповідник, я там фронтом проходив».
А мого батька контузило між селом Перекоп
і турецьким валом, коли брали Крим.
Знаєте, це як батьківський заповіт, який я послідовно виконую вже 26 років.
По суті, біосферний заповідник Асканія-Нова
довелось розбудовувати багато в чому з нуля.
Треба було забезпечити
заповідний режим на цій території,
тому що було тут і браконьєрство, і багато іншого.
Будувати структуру заповідника  відповідно до вимог міжнародного законодавства,
оскільки це біосферний заповідник.
Якщо людина входить на територію заповідної зони,
це вже порушення.
Оскільки це порушення, треба притягти хоч до мінімального покарання.
А мінімальне покарання у нас настільки велике,
як дві пачки цигарок.
Це сором.
І якщо люди, проїжджаючи вздовж
заповідного степу, бачать,
що там написано: «Шановні водії, зверніть увагу,
через 1 км починається
унікальний найбільший степовий резерват Європи,
паління заборонено».
І от, я тільки провів черговий облік
зі своїми фахівцями,
у нас на 100 метрів вздовж дороги
лежить 33 цигарки.
Люди добрі, оце культура українців?
Тільки говорити, що я українець, — це замало.
Треба діяти, як сучасний українець,
якщо ти справді переймаєшся
інтересами держави.
Я не відступаю ні перед ким, і це правильно.
Тому що, я не скажу, що у мене чисті руки,
бо вони покусані, подряпані —
десь когось ловив, препарував, досліджував, тощо.
Але в стосунках із людьми
треба завжди бути відвертими і чесними.
Тож у своїх діях я звичайно
дотримуюсь саме законодавчих норм.
І тому люди знають, що якщо людина
потрапила у наші руки,
то ми її не відпустимо,
вона звільниться тільки через суд.
Відступити я можу тільки тоді,
коли не можемо [людину] взяти.
Десь, я пам'ятаю, у 93-му році
ми догнали двох браконьєрів,
але не змогли схопити.
Ба більше, щоб не вистрілити,
я свій пістолет кинув на сидіння у машину,
людина оббігла, коли ми вже
вирвали його у нього з рук,
оббігла навколо машини, і схопила пістолет.
А патрон у патроннику був.
Я це знав, бо перед тим пересмикнув
затвор, але курок спустив.
Підходжу до цього чоловіка,
а він тримає мене на мушці.
А я йому кажу, щоб він поклав
пістолет туди, де взяв,
а сам підходжу все ближче і ближче,
щоб вибити знизу цей пістолет,
бачачи, що курок він не звів,
а просто тримає мене на мушці.
Він не витримав мого погляду,
кинув пістолет у грязюку і тікати.
Ми його знову наздогнали,
двоє було таких міцних хлопців,
що втрьох ми, звичайно,
не стали стріляти і не змогли їх взяти.
Мене питають: «А де б Леонід Данилович
міг випити чарку на природі?»
Я їм кажу: «Ви знаєте, це нікому не потрібно,
ні президенту, ні нам».
Ми як раз людей привчали,
що то є територія режимна,
і в жодному разі там не можна ставити столик,
тим більше щось святкувати.
Люди нормально зрозуміли,
ніхто на мене не тиснув.
А зараз байку розповідають,
яку розповіли працівники Служби Безпеки,
що Гавриленко там такий-сякий,
не дозволив навіть президенту чарку випити.
Я кажу: «Заради Бога, в інших місцях, хто ж проти?»
Але є конкретні місця,
де дійсно ні для кого не повинно бути дозволу.
І це правильно, це нормально.
Я дуже обурений тим,
що ми самі ніяк не можемо зрозуміти,
що зберегти людину
як біологічний вид можна тільки
за тих умов, що ми збережемо
середовище  її існування.
І від того, на скільки ми зуміємо людей виховати
шанобливо і бережливо ставитися до довкілля,
залежить майбутнє наступних поколінь.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Sasha Boole]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]